bonsoir bérengère appelle-t-il godefroy
merci d'être avec nous et d'avoir
accepté de témoigner de votre situation
sur rt france pour commencer
justement quelle est votre situation
aujourd'hui l'envié on est fermé on sait
surtout pas quand est ce qu'on va mourir
et on en a peur de ne pas pouvoir faire
noël il en attendant où on a les
factures qui tondent et on doit payer
alors entre ont un petit peu plus en
détail le premier confinement vous avez
j'imagine été aidé par le gouvernement
expliquez-nous ce qui vous pose le plus
de problème finalement aujourd'hui la
trésorerie parce qu'on premier
confinement on a été obligé d'attaquer
notre trésorerie
hélas ce sombre confinement des tiroirs
or c'est à dire que vous avez aidé été
aidée lors du premier confinement par le
gouvernement mais tout de même il
fallait que vous puisiez dans vos
réserves dans un second temps c'est bien
ça ban et 500 euros par mois c'est vrai
que c'est bien c'est déjà ça mais c'est
pas suffisant pour payer des loyers en
moi j'ai plus cher de loyer ça veut dire
que vous êtes combien dans votre salon
de beauté vous vous recevez vous êtes
salarié de ce salon et vous recevez 1500
euros en tout et pour tout c'est ça de
l'état lors de ces périodes de
confinement c'est le cas encore
aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est ça moi j'ai
une salariée et des apprentis et
aujourd'hui on obligé d'avancer les
salaires quand même donc c'est toujours
de la trésorerie même si on va nous les
rembourser alors que pensez-vous de
cette initiative des artisans et des
commerçants de poser dans le plus simple
appareil et de publier sur les réseaux
sociaux est ce que pour vous cela a peut
éveiller les consciences du gouvernement
notamment ben je trouve que c'est bien
ça mais belle image de ce qui nous
arrive on nous met à nu c'est à dire
qu'on est les premiers touchés je pense
que les normes sanitaires ont largement
été respectée dans tous les petits
commerces de proximité
que ce soit en esthétique en coiffure
importe le domaine je pense que tout le
monde a bien joué le jeu chez les petits
commerçants
et aujourd'hui c'est nous qui sommes
fermés mais que c'est nous qui sommes
vraiment banio kenny au mur quoi on
attend les aides donc on attend début
décembre mais en attendant le début
décembre à falun alors c'est vrai que je
me fais l'avocat du diable mais mais
j'imagine qu'à des téléspectateurs voilà
qui sont devant leur télé qui se disent
oui mais malheureusement tout cela est
très malheureux notamment si pour les
d'ailleurs les restaurants les coiffeurs
on l'a dit mais c'est vrai dans
l'esthétisme on est en contact
voilà les trois forcément avec avec les
clients et ce qui n'a pas un danger
justement les clients le craignent
peut-être mais aussi vos salariés alors
complètement il ya un danger les normes
sanitaires ont été tellement élevé en
esthétique que je pense que on est
largement largement bord des changements
de vous entre chaque cliente port du
masque ville hier on désinfecte à cabine
entre chaque cliente
moi personnellement il sonnait à la
porte des clients sont accueillis aux
pros de gouttes uniquement sur rendez
vous ce qui permet de gérer les kabyles
le binage tout donc je vois pas où est
le problème
justement comment ont réagi vos clientes
et clients d'ailleurs peut-être après le
premier confinement sont ils revenus
dans l'est dans les salons à
d'esthétisme où est-ce qu'ils ont eu
peur alors moi je sais pas si c'est que
chez moi mais moi les clientes sont
vraiment revenu et j'ai même gagné
nouvelles clientes enfin j'aimerais que
le mois de mai a été très fort et
l'année a été très très très fort donc
de qi mais ça suffit pas après deux mois
de fermeture
les clientes plutôt confiante finalement
et peut-être qu'ils aient envie de se
détendre après un confinement
il ya un conseil de défense jeudi avec
une évaluation de la situation sanitaire
est ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement peut infléchir sa position
et annoncé la réouverture de de ces
commerces dits non essentiels alors je
pense que certains commerces devraient
rouvrir dont nous parce qu on ne
travaille au rendez vous donc il ya des
commerçants
sincèrement où les normes peuvent cet
état peut être largement maîtrisé après
je sais pas merci en tout cas bérengère
oui vous y croyez peut en tout cas bon
courage à vous merci d'avoir été avec
nos bérengère paitier gow3 éthicienne
poudrier de génie evre merci à vous